woher kommst du immer in diese frage
einen menschen mit migrationshintergrund
fragt um eben diesen
migrationshintergrund herauszufinden ist
das noch harmloser small talk oder schon
geschmacklos wo verläuft die grenze
zwischen neugier und rassismus das wird
derzeit diskutiert unter dem hashtag von
hier viele sind wütend oder genervt hört
auf mich zu fragen wo ich herkomme auf
beiden seiten das sieht man ja wohl noch
fragen dürfen und manche sind einfach
nur verwirrt warum sind jetzt alle fügen
ich bin ja für aufklärung statt
aufregung und egal wie hitzig diese
debatte teilweise sein mag ich glaube ja
dass es so ein paar punkte gibt auf die
wir uns tatsächlich alle einigen können
ob das klappt also auf was können wir
uns denn alle einigen ich habe in dieser
debatte
vier punkte ausfindig gemacht also der
niedrigste konsens die man unaufgeregt
haben kann
doch bevor wir zu diesen vier punkten
kommen eine kurze einführung
der brigadier losgetreten wurde die
ganze debatte durch dieter bohlen und
diese szene hier
woher kommt die milch in den herrn
und mama und papa wo kommt ihr her
philippinen oder ist auch eine menge
wie wo kommt ihr her aus welchem land
gebürtig oma opa oder so bist du dir
mama ja wo kommen wir her
ich komme aus thailand teiler okay wer
bin ich auch bald bzw eigentlich erst
durch märkte wo henry und diesen tweet
dann durchfährt man auf spiegel online
dann haben sich ganz viele menschen auf
twitter beteiligt und die diskussion ist
immer noch nicht kann weil die bullen
geschichte kennen wir alle und mit wir
meine ich menschen mit sichtbarem
migrationshintergrund woher kommst du
aus nord baden württemberg ich meine
woher kommst du ursprünglich nur spryng
lich aus südhessen wenn nur deutschland
lebst und dein gesicht nicht kaukasische
ist dann ist die frage woher kommst du
ziemlich wahrscheinlich die häufigste
frage die du so im alltag von fremden
menschen gestellt bekommt die geschichte
ist also nicht neu nur wurde sie selten
so öffentlich diskutiert jetzt was ist
das problem warum mögen viele menschen
mit migrationshintergrund diese frage
nicht mit jedem woher kommst du wird man
daran erinnert dass man nicht so
aussieht die von hier das ist ungefähr
so als wärst im fußballstadium und alle
um dich rum haben das mannschaftstrikot
an nur du nicht dabei bist du im herzen
ein genauso großer drei hart fan von
dieser mannschaft doch alles was die
anderen sehen ist dass du kein trikot an
hast viele deutsche mit
migrationshintergrund fühlen sich genau
so deutsch wie deutsche ohne
migrationshintergrund und möchten auch
gerne so deutsch gesehen werden wir
wollen einfach nur deutsch sein ist es
so schwer zu verstehen doch das
fremdsein ist uns ins gesicht
geschrieben da weise deutsche menschen
dieses gefühl jetzt persönlich nicht
kennen wird es auch leicht
missverstanden vor allem weil in dieser
debatte leicht der eindruck entsteht
dass diese frage woher kommst du wie ein
schlag ins gesicht des nein so
dramatisch ist diese eine frage jetzt
auch wieder nicht ist er wie der stete
tropfen der den stein aushöhlt es ist
die häufigkeit mit der man mit dieser
frage konfrontiert wird also der alltag
ist voll mit klein aber fein
erinnerungen daran dass man
irgendwie nicht so richtig teil der crew
ist dass man irgendwie anders ist
deswegen fragen menschen mit
migrationshintergrund könnten nicht
einfach mal unsere gesichter akzeptieren
und das nicht zum thema machen jetzt
gibt es auf der anderen seite aber auch
menschen die schlicht und einfach ein
aufrichtiges interesse haben an der
herkunft des gegenübers vielleicht sich
hier absolut als deutsche möchte aber
trotzdem wissen wo seine wurzeln sind
nicht zuletzt in die ethnischen und
kulturellen wurzeln auch ein wichtiger
teil einer persönlichkeit und ein
interesse daran kann auch schön sein und
jetzt sagt man jetzt zeitlich so
unsensibel und hat auf diese frage zu
stellen oder sagt man stellt euch nicht
so an und beantwortet einfach eine
harmlose frage
und damit kommen wir jetzt zum ersten
knackpunkt oder zum ersten punkt auf den
wir uns alle einigen sollten
wir können nicht wissen wie andere sich
fühlen
vor allem weil wir hier über typische
smalltalk situation sprechen wo sich
zwei menschen begegnen die sich gerade
erst getroffen haben mir mich als
beispiel ich heiße meine eltern sind wir
beim lesen und niemand weiß wie man
meinen vollen namen ausspricht hören wir
zu ähnlich ausgesprochen wie das nur
informieren werkstatt martin nürnberg
sagt man einfach mal die mühe gibt nicht
so schwer oder spinnen etwa im ak
vettelheim geboren und in hemsbach an
der bergstraße aufgewachsen
unschwer zu erkennen an der art und
weise wie ich gehe hier in ausspreche
sagte hirt gehirns gehirn heißt nicht
wie hier ich bin deutscher ich fühle
mich auch so aber wenn mich jemand fragt
wo ich herkomme dann antworte ich
meistens ganz gerne und sagte dass meine
eltern aus vietnam kommt ja die frage
wird oft etwas unbeholfen formuliert
aber solange ich das gefühl habe dass
die motivation der frage einfach neugier
ist bin ich persönlich cool damit aber
die journalistin vanessa wo zum beispiel
hat zwar auch vietnamesische eltern hat
aber ganz andere erfahrungen gemacht
hier schreibt sie sehr eindrücklich
warum die frage nach ihrer herkunft mit
ziemlich viel persönlichen schmerz
verknüpft ist und dass sie deswegen
schlicht und einfach keine lust hat
darüber zu reden vor allem nicht mit
menschen die sie gerade erst getroffen
hat und meine eltern zum beispiel
antworten immer sehr gerne und fröhlich
und unbefangen auf die fragen
nach ihrer herkunft und das auch in
vielen fällen in denen ich nicht so cool
reagieren würde meinen eltern bekommt
die frage nämlich manchmal einen
unschönen beigeschmack regelmäßig werden
sie zum beispiel gefragt und warum leben
sie in deutschland und dann gehen sie
wieder zurück was wir werden sie sogar
nach ihrem beruf gefragt gefolgt von der
frage und warum arbeiten sie nicht in
vietnam
das ist dann kein aufrichtiges interesse
mehr sondern eine deutliche ausgrenzung
ein klares sie gehören nicht hierhin
versteht ihr das waren jetzt gerade
einfach drei einzelne erfahrungsberichte
in diesem fall von vietnamesen in
deutschland aber es gibt ja noch viel
mehr menschen mit vielen verschiedenen
hintergründen und geschichten und
erfahrungen und ich kann unmöglich meine
persönlichen erfahrungen auf andere
übertragen und deswegen kann ich auch
nicht als fragender verlangen dass sich
der andere nicht so anstellen soll oder
nicht so empfindlich sein soll weil ich
kann einem anderen menschen einfach
nicht seine persönlichen erfahrungen und
seine persönlichen gefühle absprechen ok
komme jetzt aber zur anderen seite des
dialogs hier gibt es auch einen punkt
auf den wir uns meiner meinung nach alle
einigen sollten und zwar die absicht ist
wichtig aus unwissenheit können wir
andere verletzen
zum beispiel weil wir nicht wissen wie
sich andere fühlen trotzdem ist es
natürlich wichtig ob ich die absicht
habe jemanden zu verletzen oder nicht
und trotzdem höre ich in dieser debatte
immer wieder es ist egal ob das jemand
eigentlich nicht meint es ist ein
gefährliches ich weiß es ist völlig
legitim zu sagen was ist nicht böse
gemeint aber mich hat es trotzdem
verletzt oder war es nicht böse gemeint
aber ich mag diese frage nicht und werde
sie nicht beantworten für die legitim
aber wenn man sagt du hast es nicht böse
gemeint aber darauf kommt es nicht an
dann ist man jetzt hier einfach einen
schritt zu weit gegangen denn natürlich
kommt es darauf an natürlich ist es
wichtig ob jemand aufrichtiges interesse
hat nervige vorurteile oder brennen
haas hielt das ist doch nicht egal es
macht einen unterschied ob jemand wissen
möchte ob ich aus vietnam bin weil er
mir dann mit leuchtenden augen von
seinem urlaub erzählen möchte oder ob er
mir danach sagt dass ich da hin zurück
gehen soll wenn wir fremdenhass in einen
topf werfen mit unbeholfenheit dann ist
das nicht nur sehr unfair für die
unbeholfenen menschen sondern es mindert
natürlich auch die grausame bedeutung
von hass und rassismus tut so viel zur
theorie aber wie verhalten wir uns jetzt
in der praxis und ihnen kommen wir zur
nächsten sache auf die wir uns alle
einigen sollten nämlich das ewige ping
pong spiel ist niemandem weiter mit ping
pong spiel meine ich diese klassische
bohlen situation kommst du ursprünglich
aus deutschland ich meine ruhe kommst du
eigentlich aus hemsbach also ich meine
kämpfe an der bergstraße kämpfe
konversation ist halt einfach nicht
lösungsorientiert erstmal an die fragen
denn wenn ihr eigentlich wissen wollte
woher kommen deine gene ihr aber eine
antwort bekommt wie fenster an der
bergstraße den kids dafür eigentlich nur
zwei plausible gründe aber gegenüber hat
euch sehr wohl verstanden ist aber schon
mal mindestens genervt und hat einfach
keinen bock diese frage zu beantworten
oder bayer gegenüber ist ein
fünfjähriges mädchen das hier in
deutschland aufgewachsen ist und keine
ahnung hat wovon jeder redet schon
deshalb ist nachfragen einfach nicht
zielführend mit jedem nachfragen werdet
ihr nur mehr missmutiger mehr verwirrung
stiften
doch auch die gefragten tragen nicht zur
lösung bei ich meine wir wir sind doch
ganz genau was diese armen menschen
versuchen herauszufinden solche
spielchen stiften ja nur verwirrung vor
allem wende andere ja gar nicht weiß
warum ihr euch gerade nervt und dann
wird in zukunft die nächsten fragen
woher kommt weil er immer noch nicht
weiß was er eigentlich falsch gemacht
hat was wäre stattdessen zielführend
erstmal
an die fragenden geht doch einfach auf
die antwort ein woher kommst du aus
hemsbach kenne ich nicht wo ist das wenn
ihr euch aufrichtig für die herkunft
eines menschen interessiert dann sollte
der ort an dem er aufgewachsen ist
genauso interessant sein wie seine
ethnische wurzeln in der nähe von nach
denen könnt ihr jetzt immer noch fragen
was dann viel natürlicher wirkt trotz
asiatische wurzeln oder außerdem macht
euch bewusst dass die frage nach der
herkunft nicht unbedingt eine leichte
smalltalk frage ist sondern auch mit
viel emotionalen ballast belastet sein
kann wenn man das auf dem schirm hat
kann man die frage auch ein bisschen
sensibler stellen darf ich dich etwas
persönliches fragen was sind deine
wurzeln und an die gefragten man kann ja
zum beispiel respektvoll darauf
hinweisen dass herkunft etwas
vielschichtiges ist ausweis jetzt damit
wo ich herkomme oder meine wurzeln und
werden einen die frage nervt kann man
das ja vielleicht auch höflich sagen
ehrlich gesagt nervt mich diese frage
zieht mich weil ich mich dadurch
ausgegrenzt fühle in meinem eigenen
heimatland aber ich weiß dass du es
nicht böse gemeint hast und wenn ihr
keinen bock ab drüber zu reden
absolut verständlich das ist ja auch
anstrengend ich will ja auch nicht immer
so eine riesenkiste aufmachen wenn ich
eigentlich nur smalltalk halten möchte
es ist euer gutes recht diese frage
nicht zu beantworten aber dann ist es
nicht euer recht euch über die
unwissenheit aufzuregen denn damit
kommen wir zum letzten punkt auf den wir
uns alle einigen sollten nämlich
aufklärung ist die einzige lösung gegen
unwissenheit und paar alle an steigungen
wenn wir die wir es persönlich erleben
nicht aufklären wer dann heißt das ihr
das erste video sein sollte dass ihr mit
mir sei lieb ist normalerweise ein
wissenschafts kanal aber weil es halt
auch mal app ist ist es halt main kanal
und als deutsch vietnamesen wollte ich
das gerne loswerden
aber nächste woche geht es regulär
weiter mit silence wenn ich das
interessiert könnt ihr natürlich gerne
abonnieren wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag bis dahin
leipzig